i love this man i probably did more nfl
total accesses with this guy as my
analyst than anybody else he is a pro
football hall of famer a little bit of
raiders a little bit of ravens a lot of
black and gold from the steelers and
certainly from his days in purdue one of
my favorites ron woodson back here on
the rich eisen show how are you ron
rich i am so glad to talk to you because
you are becoming big time and you're
everywhere what do you mean
what are you talking about you're just
everywhere you're like westwood one your
directv i mean you got podcasts you're
just
i'm glad i knew you before
[Laughter]
that's all i'm saying i'm glad i knew
you before
i'm still the same guy rod still the
same i know you are that's what i love
about you because all your success has
not given you the big kid what you can
to some people okay thank you i
appreciate that oh well richie richie
rich is still richie that's right
still humble beginnings even though nfl
network built this gorgeous new facility
in studio rod you were there when i was
doing total access from the same rickety
chair for seven eight years
you heard the creaking as i sat down and
it looked at you and you looked at me
thought this was going to be the time
the chair breaks on live television you
were there for all those shows right
way back i was and it was fun it sure
was okay let's get into it what do you
make of the kansas city chiefs rod when
you looked at them last night you've
seen them for eight weeks what do you
have for me you know
it's just first of all you can't be
minus 11 turnover margin right you can't
have
19 turnovers
by far the most in the national football
league through the first seven weeks it
just can't happen and you can't think
you're going to win football games that
way
i i think they're just pushing you know
they
they're
decently well running the football
i just think patrick mahomes and the
offense is just trying to do too much
they're always trying to hit a home run
every play
on every down and if you watch that game
you know
he at times took what the defense gave
me
but he still tried to push it down the
field because i think that's what
everybody expects of the kansas city
chiefs so i'm a little surprised that
that hasn't changed yet and i think eric
vinomy and i think coach reed i think
they'll get that straightened out on the
offensive side of it
they just got to take care of the
football uh defensively
you know it was really good to see them
kind of you know come on come around and
make some plays on the defensive side uh
you know
frank you know he um he hasn't been he's
been kind of banged up and beat up
throughout the whole year
so hopefully they'll just keep getting
better on the side of it and if they can
do that then you know hopefully they can
win some football games yeah i know i
just i go back and forth between yeah if
they just cut out the turnovers they'll
be fine
and then i see how they played
defensively but then i saw the way they
played defensively last night and then i
say yeah but that was you know a giants
offense that's missing tons of parts and
have a has a quarterback in daniel jones
who i still don't know if he can be a
championship quarterback in this league
so the evaluation just keeps kind of
changing and shifting but i
eventually just land on the fact
that they have some tremendously
talented players
that they do with a staff that knows how
to deploy them
and if
so is a super bowl hangover real rod is
that real because that's also what kind
of looks like what they're going through
right now
i don't believe in jinx and all that
stuff right um but it sure seems like it
you know
it just seems like when you get there
and you lose
you know
hey i go back to when i was with the
raiders you know we we get there in 2002
and the next year man we look terrible
we're just awful
so you know is it there i i think
you know losing getting so far and
losing
does have uh kind of a deflation for the
football team but at the end of the day
you know you have players and kansas
city you know chris jones kind of showed
up for him last night you know you know
clark um
clark
you know he showed up but he's been and
he's been banged up and beat up even
after the game he was olympian
you know kind of to the
to the tunnel um so you can kind of see
where they're kind of beat up and banged
up a little bit
and they do have so much talent um
and you know i just think they're
pushing i just think they
you know they've been so explosive
for the last couple years and we expect
everybody in the world who watches
football expect them to throw the ball
down the field and tyra kill and travel
with kelsey and making those big plays
and they've been they've been pushing it
and i think when you do that and you
you're not confident with a young
offensive line which they have i think
they're getting better i i don't know if
patrick mahomes really trust that
offensive line yet because sometimes
the pocket isn't collapsed and he still
gets out of it and you know so i
that tells me that he believes that it's
going to be collapsed right it's going
to get pushed inside and he's going to
have to get out anyway um but i think
it's a long season this is the first
year for 17 games um i i know there's a
lot of football left
if the defense can get halfway there if
they can just not have the turnovers
they can win some football games because
they look and you did say it
i didn't want to
disparage the new york giants offense
you know they played against the new
york giants offense and they don't they
don't have a lot of their weapons
um but at the end of the day they play
who they play and they played well
enough to win
and in the national football league
that's what matters
rod woodson here on the rich eisens show
what's going through von miller's mind
right now i know when you left
pittsburgh and you left your black and
gold heart there which you've you know
obviously you're you're back there now
and great good graces
but and and miller is in great good
graces in denver as well as he leaves
but is there gonna is what's that gonna
be like when he puts on a rams uniform
for the first time and gets to know a
new organization rod what's that going
to be i mean i i felt for him because it
was completely different circumstances
for him and me
i mean i left on my own accord
because of the contract situation
he goes into the facility thinking he's
still a bronco right and they tell him
hey uh you need to go see the front
office and they tell him he got traded
so you know it kind of hit him at you
know kind of all at once
and watching his interview how he got
shook up a little bit and kind of
emotional at the end of that i mean it's
i i feel for him for that now with that
being said
i was about to say do you feel for him
more than the quarterbacks that are
going to face the rams with no i mean
that's what i was going to go to i know
i feel for him personally
because he his heart is in denver
right right and he did so many good
things in denver
but man oh my gosh
i mean you got aaron donald
you got leonard floyd right
now you put bond miller on the other
side of that and ramsay on the back end
too and the ramsey on the back end and
what i love about what they're dealing
with ramsey what they did last year is
they're playing them at nickel too so
you know just having those type of
players
on the team and it's really it's they're
telling us with that move they're all in
this year oh yeah
i mean they're this this is a super bowl
bust
for them and
you got to play against tampa bay you
got to play against aaron rodgers you
got to play against kyle murray you
better have some pass rushers
so yeah i i love the move um i i think
it's going to be a devastating defense
uh raheem morse has a lot to work with
so
you know i'm looking forward to seeing
what they can do with this group
especially since you take a look at the
nfc as a whole rod as you said that the
rams are all in and you could say they
were kind of all in this year anyway
with ramsey and donald and who knows how
long you can be oh look i don't have
their ledger and less need has been
phenomenal trying to figure out how to
pull these you know pieces together cap
wise or what have you uh donald and
ramsey and then you go and get stafford
and trade away first round picks to get
out of the golf contract and get
stafford in you could already make a
case they were pot committed now they're
all all in and so is green bay because
you don't know what's going on with
rogers this could be the last dance
there the bucks have been operating
since they signed brady as there's no
tomorrow like that it's win for today
win now
and then you mention the cardinals they
get you know uh jj watt unfortunately
he's hurt aj green zach ertz they're
adding to win now it's just a pot
committed conference with the cowboys
looking as good as they have had in a
long time i'm loving this rod loving it
you know i i do too i i really don't
know
who the best team in the league is
anymore right now i mean i think there's
so much parody right now
at the top
that
it's if somebody said one team is better
than the other they're lying
because you just don't know these these
you know top-notch teams especially in
the nfc i think the nfc has shown
their wear this year
that they have the best teams in the
league when you talk about green bay and
arizona even dallas how great they have
really looked uh tampa bay and rams and
believe it or not i i need to see where
they go
you know after you know james winston
getting hurt right but the new orleans
saints have played extremely well
this year not and it was led by the
defense so
you know if simeon comes in and he's the
starting quarterback and the defense
still plays well then they they could be
a heart out especially if tampa bay
meets them
in the postseason
yeah and that's something that
you know tom brady has struggled he
struggled with the new orleans defense
so yeah because if the saints win this
week rob uh the buccaneers will be a
wild card team after after eight games
because
the bucks would have the same record as
the saints the saints just beat him i
mean that's it's just a a and then
you're assuming the niners are gonna
have to get better and then you know
that's the nfc
then you've got the afc with the power
vacuum i guess we're kind of going a
little full circle with you rod woodson
pro football hall of famer here on the
rich eisen show kind of going full
circle here because the chiefs have left
the power vacuum because they're 500 you
got the raiders at five and two you've
got the bills
now having come off the buy they're five
and two
and then you've got the six and two
titans but without derrick henry now for
potentially the rest of the season the
ravens get boat raced by the bengals who
then lose to mike white in the jets you
know
so
who's the best team in the afc right now
the steelers are now in the mix too i'll
go let's throw them back in the mix
they're a succeed so i'll give you that
that's a great question um
tennessee
you know
when you have derrick henry just a grown
man running the football you know i've
seen big running backs but that guy he
was that size when he's 18 years old
you know it's just crazy that he he is
that big now
you said that he might be gone for the
whole year i don't see him coming back
unless frank
man that's just
unless he's just a miraculous healer
right
there's no way he's coming back and
cutting
on his foot again
this year because they're going to put a
pin in it depending you know i know a
lot of guys who've had a lift frank
sometimes they got to put a pin in it
sometimes that pin works sometimes it
doesn't sometimes they got to put bone
fragments in it and graph it that way
sometimes that works sometimes it
doesn't that's one of those injuries
that you just don't know how the guy's
going to be
in the future but with that being said
ryan tannehill it's you know we're going
to see how good he is
without derrick henry
because everybody they stacked the box
they stacked the box because they knew
derrick cameron was gonna you you know
he can have that one play
where he can change the the tide of a
football game now
that threat's not there anymore so now
you can play a two shell
you know they you know they're probably
still gonna try to run the ball they're
gonna try to stay
true to who they are but they don't have
their henry back there anymore
so i don't think defense coordinators
are gonna worry about that so we're
gonna see how good ryan tanago is and
let me say about vegas um derek carr has
played extremely well he sure has he
sure has the year i was coaching with
him and i think that was at 2016 where
he uh we were 12-4
man he was lights out before he got hurt
i thought he was an mvp race uh you know
he should have been
in that uh category
i think he's there again um i think
they're a really good football team
um
derek carr has taken upon himself to be
that leader of that football team
um and so i'm i'm surprised that the
defense has gotten this good this fast
that's what i'm really surprised about
i'm not surprised about derek carr but
i'm really surprised about the defense
right in baltimore heck you know we
thought they were going to be
you know they get waxed by cincinnati we
thought they were done forever
and now they're they're just five and
two uh i i i don't know if they're you
can say if there's one team that's the
best team in
the afc uh i think there are a bunch of
really good teams in amc right i think
the best teams all lie in the nfc i
really do and i would be
surprised if the one of the whoever came
out of that nfc battle
and got to the super bowl didn't win the
super bowl
i don't know the bills are pretty damn
stout you know i know they lost to
tennessee and i i
lost tennessee and they shouldn't have
lost to the steelers either you know
what i mean and they should not have
lost to the steelers yeah i thought that
block punt yeah because they could be
seven though i i do love buffalo
i'm just saying as i see everybody and
the way the game is played and what i
love about
buffalo you do have josh allen who's on
my fantasy team he's my quarterback i'm
gonna play better week in and week out
okay um
but
they their defense is really good and
they turn the ball over and leslie
you know if he doesn't get an
opportunity to be a head coach again
shame on the national football right
because i think he deserves it um i
think he shows his where
as being a coordinator in the league um
he is
year in a year out has put a good
product on the field so
buffalo is a good team uh i do give i do
believe in that uh rich
but i just don't know if any of those
teams are better than the nfc teams
so and that's because because they're
going to beat each other up
and whoever comes out of that
i just think they're the best team in
the league so uh quick follow-up and
then one last question uh what's the
name of your fantasy team what's the
name of your fantasy team rod woodson
what is that cat who dat cat um and the
and the uh the avatar is of an actual
cat what's the photograph
no it's um
my fantasy team is with the nfl alumni
legends or whatever they call them i
don't even i don't even know i just let
them give me whatever avatar they gave
me okay so who's winning who's winning
the nfl legends community uh fantasy
football league through eight weeks
it's not me i'm only three and five okay
so who is who who else i don't know i
don't i didn't look i'm i'm a bitter i'm
very i'm a bitter loser uh you know i'm
a sore loser i'm just
when i when i saw i was three and five i
won yesterday okay a point right so i'm
hoping it's a long year hoping i can get
back into this whole thing and my
running backs who are
not great hopefully they can come up and
help me a little bit so that that sounds
to me rod uh is it are you losing the
webster slaughter again is that what's
happening
yeah yeah i mean
i lost a couple to webster
that's one of my favorite names to bring
up to you okay um and then last one for
you rod uh who is the toughest running
back for you to take down you mentioned
about derek henry now adrian peterson
he's taking his who who's the guy that
you were played against is my time frame
yeah your time frame where you made a
business decision you're like okay kevin
mack
kevin mack that's it huh yes listen
kevin mac was like i don't know if he's
five ten-ish something like that and he
didn't have a neck i think he had this
one right to his shoulder
and i mean he was just so powerful and
he knocked out greg lloyd in the game he
knocked out another safety in the game
like in one game he knocked out three
people
and i was like oh my goodness and i
didn't know how to talk to the guy
because he was so stout
he was the one guy that i went up there
i was trying to figure out how i'm gonna
hit this dude he's the only one in my 17
years of playing
that i was trying to figure out if i'm
going to hit him low
or if i'm not trying to throw a receiver
down on him and he hopefully he trips
over the guy
you know it was it was tough but he was
the guy that that made me think
if i was going to make a business
decision and let him run by me it was
going to be that guy
did you ever though did you ever no no
okay no okay no come rich at the end of
the day yes i'm a blue collar guy from
the midwest that's right we play tackle
football in the streets man in the
winter
right in front of the cars and if you
slide hit the car you're out of bounds
you know
that's
if i i'm just saying if i had to make a
business decision i never did right if i
had to make one
it would have been with him
because i seen him devastate greg lloyd
another two of our other safeties
and he came back my matter of fact he
came back my way one time in that same
game
and i had i don't know if i it was
what's the slaughter of the other little
receiver they had and i threw him down
and
he tripped over him
well we're seeing
we're just we're putting a photograph of
him up on the screen right now rod
um and he doesn't have a neck does he
i don't
it's a head and shoulder pads that's
what i'm saying
he's officially listed at six foot 225.
he's six foot he was that big
that's what pro football reference is
saying
well i was hoping he was smaller but
yeah that's five i mean that think about
that and he's running straight downhill
oh man roger i mean that's the name of
ibax
iso and they were trying to hurt you
love you rod woodson thanks for the call
let's do this more often i would love to
do this all right rich as much as you're
willing take care all right brother you
got it that's rod woodson the greatest
kevin mack
no thank you hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here